So again let’s use our Jersey Square team as an
example of what customer relationships might
look like. If you remember we keep talking about
get, keep and grow. But what does that exactly
look like. What is it that you are doing. Well
getting customers is just like it sounds. I need to
acquire them and activate them. And if you
remember Jersey Square team said, my primary
channel will be our own company website. So,
therefore probably my number one way of getting
customers are Google AdWords. And you can see
the little experiments that they ran here in the
bottom and they are doing a whole bunch A/B
testing and Google AdWord testing and Facebook
testing. But they are trying to see whether that
hypothesis about low cost acquisition is possible.
They’re also doing gross marketing on Facebook,
YouTube and Twitter and they’re trying to see
whether they can make their business viral by
actually having customers who refer others. The
key tenet of virality is can you get other people to
do your marketing for free. And they are also
going to work on targeted promotions. All these
right now are hypothesis, but pretty good starting
points. But later on they’re thinking about what
their funnel like in year two or three. How are
they going to keep these customers. Again these
are further out hypotheses but we’re thinking
about customer royalty programs, seniority
credits, partnership rewards, free jersey
giveaways. And ultimately can they grow their
customer base? Can they sell their customer
data? Can they have a family plan? It’s not only
you wear a jersey, but you could have your wife
and children and we’ll ship the entire box jerseys
for every game to you. Premium subscriptions and
possibly you could actually rent out additional
products like phone fingers, noise makers, funny
hats etcetera that actually might come in the
shipping box. And now you’re getting a higher
average selling price.